[Music]
foreign
how did we miss this indeed true this
story slipped through our fingers
somehow but we decided to cover it
anyway because it's the greatest story
in the history of stories a team of
doctors set out to research a simple
question if you swallowed a Lego how
long would it take to poop it out
but it helped answer a much deeper
question that this is exactly what
doctors do while we're waiting in their
exam room wearing nothing but a paper
robe
the story is from 2018 but it's just too
hard to pass
shut up it's got all the Hallmarks of a
great Gutfeld story science poop science
about poop this poop belonged to the
Canadian shop teacher with huge bazookas
my head would explode
as to why anyone besides me would fund
this kind of research well as you know
kids are dumb and frequently swallow
toys which causes their parents to panic
although when I was a lad I was fed a
steady diet of Lincoln Logs
yeah Delicious By the way kids aren't
the only ones who swallow toys
six six doctors wanted to test the
relative harm of ingesting Legos so they
did just that they tracked the time
taken for the Lego to be found in their
stool using the found and retrieved time
or fart score
is this real
if this is dated April 1st 2018 or
something
gonna get one or two people shorter
turns out most adults passed the Lego in
one to three days and that even for kids
is not a big deal apparently but with
any good research it's important to
repeat the experiment to see if you can
duplicate the findings
right
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up Joe you're still selling
those Lego sets on eBay yeah it's good
money but put them together is murder
[Applause]
nice perfect
cat it is real but would you consider
this a waste of research funding
human waste
you're done no he's got more I was gonna
say you definitely have more I was just
waiting
probably and I would never risk this
because I already had a chapter five and
I don't want to have another one yes
I didn't know you could eat Legos
because I don't think you can you can
cut up your stomach you got a dog that
eats everything right has he ever eaten
so do you oh yeah my dog eats a lot of
things it's got worms no he doesn't have
worms he's got parasites okay let's get
off this topic you picked it I did pick
it Aaron this is the greatest story ever
it's uh very weird I just can't imagine
that like something would be worse than
stepping on a Lego and then eating one
and then trying to pass it like that
just seems terrible with your butt
stepping on it with your butt that's my
next point it just this just doesn't
seem like a good use of science yeah
yeah I can tell Terry by our audience
going very quiet that this is a Surefire
ratings winner of a story
this is why this is this is sort of why
you've had such a meteoric rise in Media
clearly uh you know I did a little uh
extra digging so to speak
unlike you uh who just was like is this
real I looked into it yeah right I
actually did my homework and there's a
dude in there yeah who couldn't they
actually there was a bunch of n a not
applicable not applicable and they're
trying to track when it came out he
could not find it oh so there was a dude
who for several weeks was Trump was
going through his poop and he could not
find the Lego I find that fascinating
yeah I do too I find that fascinating
and I also think that why why would you
just why would you limit yourself to one
little piece of Lego like those are
rookie numbers why don't you why don't
you swallow like a Lego Batman or an
X-Wing Fighter yeah or a small building
I mean really that's check or if you're
really you know gutsy do the study in
Reverse exactly yeah
my man
Tom you're a scientific man of Reason
could you explain to me the scientific
benefits of such research what would you
learn from this besides the obvious
there has to be a reason why this is
being done oh scientific man of Reason
yes well
yes sir scientific man you're dressed as
one I did read the story like you and I
I wasn't sure if they I couldn't really
figure out what the answer was I don't
know if they provided us with an actual
answer of how long it takes a Lego to go
through your body but I also think this
it wasn't a very good experiment because
it's a Lego I've often wondered the
actual question which is how long before
the food that you eat you know becomes
the the other thing right right right
right so and when I've tried to do that
research it says a certain amount of
time and in my experience I don't want
to get too graphic about this stuff but
it's the thing is I don't ever think I
think that it's a shorter period of time
than I I read about in the medical
journals yeah and it gets shorter the
older you get
because your intestines are shrinking
it's like you get it like your food gets
one of those passes for the carpool I
disagree
I disagree I think the motility of your
intestine actually slows down when you
get older due to neural degeneration I
think it takes longer to get uh just
because
it's a man of science no I just we got
to move on but I just wanna I wanna
lecture our audience who are silent in
their disapproval of this topic I'm sure
that or mocked Sir Isaac Newton when he
just when he discovered electricity
that's right when the lightning
when the lightning hit that Apple that's
right and he came in he says look what
happened to the apple and and and then
the printing press was made
so that's how it's going to work we're
gonna have edible you know what's we
know what this is we're gonna have
edible Legos yes that's what this is
about edible Legos why not all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else